-Our next guest
is a talented actress
who made her debut in
the Disney+ series "Ms. Marvel."
She returns as Kamala Khan
in the new movie, "The Marvels,"
which is in theaters now.
Let's take a look.
-Whoa!
-Unh!
-Friends of yours?
-Hi.
♪♪
-Unh!
-Please welcome back to the show
Iman Vellani, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-I am so happy you're back,
Iman.
-I'm so glad to be here.
-That is such a fantastic clip.
And I watch a clip like that,
and I think, "Oh, my God.
That probably is like
two days of work."
-I think when
it's really me, one.
-Okay.
-I have a CG double.
-There's a -- oh, CG double.
Okay.
-Yeah, she's great.
-Can you --
You can't do
the full barrel roll
in the sky like that?
-Can you?
-No, that's true.
[ Laughter ]
How dare you put me
in my place like that?
-That's two things
we have in common.
[ Laughter ]
-Before we get to the movie,
I'm so --
I was so excited to hear --
You were watching
"The Sopranos."
-Yeah.
-And I'm so happy
when younger people
find that show.
And then it broke my heart
when I realized
it came out
before you were born.
-Uh-oh.
-Yeah.
I'm not the only one
who's bummed out by that fact.
-2002, baby.
Are you enjoying it?
-I am.
Like, every time
I watch a new show,
I, like, kind of take
that personality.
I'm like, "Tony and Adriana,
you got all that from gabagool?"
Like, it's just so good.
-They must be so happy
they finished filming the movie.
[ Laughter ]
You didn't show up to set and
you're like, "I got a new way
I'm gonna do the character."
-I know.
No, I've been --
I've been pretty productive.
-Yeah. You -- Another thing
that's very fun for me.
Every time we talk about you
as Ms. Marvel
is that you dressed --
Before you were Ms. Marvel,
you dressed up like her
on Halloween.
-Yeah.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-I mean, that's amazing.
-My grandma helped
sew this whole thing together.
-That's fantastic.
-Now I got a whole department
for that.
-And you still continued to --
You are a Marvel fan.
You were Tony Stark one year.
[ Laughter ]
And here you are
as Jubilee.
Is Jubilee recent? Is that?
-That is. Okay.
So, I've, like, been really
into "X-Men" lately.
I am actually writing
a comic book.
-I know.
We're gonna get to that.
-Okay.
Sorry, I'm spoiling it.
I needed to do a lot
of "X-Men" research,
and I never really read
those comics
because they're so intimidating.
There's a million of them.
-Yes, there are, yes.
So I watched, like, the "X-Men"
'90s cartoon in the background.
I had, like, Grant Morrison's
"New X-Men" on my laptop.
And then I was, like, reading
Jonathan Hickman's new "X-Men."
It was, like, so much "X-Men"
all at once,
and I just had to dress up.
-Now, when you dress up
in costume,
I know you've done it as sort
of events where fans are there.
Do they recognize
you right away,
or can you sort of
remain anonymous?
-You can, like, see
the gears turning.
I mean, I was wearing a mask,
which is, like, still nice,
but you stand out more
because people are like,
"COVID still exists."
-Oh, you're wearing
that kind of mask?
We are talking
about superheroes,
so forgive me for thinking
this kind of mask.
[ Laughter ]
So, this is -- this is --
I'm so -- I'm so impressed
that you did this.
This is your comic
that you wrote, and, uh...
[ Cheers and applause ]
Four issues.
Three are out, one to go.
-One to go.
-And how have you enjoyed
the process of writing
your own comic book?
-It's the most
special thing ever.
I can't be on your show
without bringing up Sana Amanat.
She's the reason this happened.
She co-created the character,
and she made a couple calls
to Marvel editorial
and forced them
to let me write it.
And I really don't know what she
said to them, but it's real.
And that's my last name,
which is so cool.
-Yeah.
-It's great.
We were just talking about
how cool it is
to receive art every morning.
-Yes, 'cause you just
write a script,
and then you send it off,
and then, like,
drawings come back.
You cannot believe it.
-Yeah, it's either the most
validating thing when they,
like, write --
they draw exactly
what you wrote,
or you're like, "Okay.
Maybe I need to fix
my writing a little bit."
-Did you have
any hard conversations
where you realized, not that
they did something wrong,
but you wrote it
in a way that was unclear
and they did something right,
but you got it wrong, and you
had to be like, "I'm so sorry"?
-I'm just gonna say
I'm wrong because they're
probably going to watch this.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think it's always the best.
I mean, again, if you --
they're so talented
that if they draw something
the wrong way --
That's what we found.
I wrote one with Bill Hader.
-I know.
-Oh, you do?
-I read it, like,
right before coming here.
It is like, you can imagine
two dudes writing that comic.
[ Laughter ]
It's like -- It's like --
I mean that in the best way
possible.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But, okay --
But listen to the story.
-It's like -- It's like
Spider-Man, and then --
and then a dude dressed up
as Spider-Man on Halloween,
and he's, like, wasted.
Okay?
And then the two
of them switch places,
and the bad guy thinks he got
Spider-Man,
but he got the drunk Spider-Man.
It's -- It's great.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-By the way, I'm --
You might -- I'm --
This is the most anyone's
ever talked about our issue.
This is the best thing
that's ever happened to me.
-I'm glad
I'm putting it on the map.
-Yeah. And guess what --
joke's on you.
Two dudes did write it.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I was surprised to hear
that Billy Joel
was an inspiration
in any way,
shape, or form
for your comic-book writing.
-Yes, I am obsessed
with "River of Dreams."
It's like my one of my favorite
albums, my favorite song.
And it's like --
he very much explores,
you know, where we go in --
I mean, it's a play on stream of
consciousness and dealing with
our inner demons
and, you know, finding yourself.
And I think that's a lot of what
Kamala's journey is in my book.
She's a mutant now, and that's
a whole new label that she
has to adapt to.
And, you know,
the entire world's perspective
kind of shifts on her
now that she has this label
and her own --
how she perceives herself
has shifted.
So, yeah, we literally put her
in her own dreams,
and she has to fight off her
fears and doubts. It's great.
-That's fantastic.
I think you're probably
one of the few people
that uses Billy Joel
to write your mutant comics.
-Oh, God.
[ Laughter ]
I hope he serenades me
one day with that song.
[ Laughter ]
-We got to see, in the clip,
that you got to work
with the great Sam Jackson.
What is it like?
Because again, you're not
just a wonderful performer.
You are also a fan
of these films.
And Sam Jackson, obviously, not
just in the Marvel Universe
but in the entire cinematic
universe is a big deal.
What was he like?
-What was he like?
Um...
[ Laughter ]
Every time I stare at him,
this like 16x9 frame
would appear around him.
It was the weirdest thing.
He's a very generous
scene partner,
a very encouraging
scene partner.
I was doing that fight scene
with him, actually,
and he -- I wanted
to try something new,
so I high-fived him
at the end of the scene.
-Right.
-Creative choices, people.
And then -- And then we cut,
and Sam goes,
"They won't use that take."
[ Laughter ]
"Do you know why
they won't use that take?"
And I was like...
And he's like, "Your hand
was covering your face."
-Ahh!
-And I was like, "Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry
I ruined this for us!"
And he's like, "Okay.
On the next one, elbow me."
And I was like, "What?"
He's like, "Yeah, elbow me."
I was like, "Okay."
So we get to the end
of the scene, and I, like,
so scared of touching
Sam Jackson.
I like lightly elbowed him,
and then we cut.
He's like, "No, no no no!
Elbow me!"
And I was like,
"Okay, I'm sorry!"
We do another take.
I fully chickened out.
Could not figure out
the maneuvering of an elbow.
Did not do it, and he goes --
He grabs my arm and, like,
turns to me, and he's like,
"Elbow me, mother [bleep]!"
And I was like, "Listen..."
[ Laughter, cheers, applause ]
For the record,
he didn't actually swear at me.
That's just how I heard it.
I was trying to get him
to swear at me for so long.
-He wouldn't do it.
-Nothing but hugs.
-Yeah, nothing but hugs.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
I'm so glad you gave us
the multiverse version
of Sam Jackson.
[ Laughter ]
You told the story where he did
call you a mother [bleep].
-Yeah, it was a dream.
-It was a dream.
I love that those
are your two dreams --
"Oh, my God. If Billy Joel
would serenade me
while Sam Jackson
called me a mother [bleep]."
[ Laughter and applause ]
"What more could a kid
ever ask for?"
-I want that on my gravestone.
-Yes, exactly.
Hey, you know, because you are
informed on this universe,
I heard there's times on set
where you actually
catch something
that maybe doesn't
make perfect sense.
-Yes. I've e-mailed
our director, Nia DaCosta,
like, a laundry list
of plot holes,
and, like,
"I don't think Sam Jackson
would actually say this,
but here's what
he could say instead."
I'm sure
she very much appreciated
all of that unsolicited advice.
[ Laughter ]
But, no, there was, like,
literally one day on set,
I pointed something out really
early while we were filming it,
and I'm like,
"This doesn't make sense."
And they were like,
"Iman, just like, chill.
Sit down for one second."
And then, like,
half the day goes by,
and then suddenly
Nia notices.
"Hey, this actually
doesn't make sense."
And then Teyonah goes,
"No, you're right."
And I'm sitting there.
"It's almost like someone
told you."
[ Laughter ]
Um, so, yeah, I only --
-So you were cool about.
-I was cool about it, totally.
It's not in the movie
anymore, either, so...
-All right.
Well, you were right again.
And it is just so wonderful
to have you back here.
I am so thrilled that
the strike is over
so you can be out promoting
this wonderful film
and your wonderful comic.
You guys, that's Iman Vellani.
"The Marvels"
is in theaters now.
Her comic book is on the racks.
We'll be right back
with more "Late Night."